and Colter the conservative pundit and
author there she is we have a picture of
her was she came to the roast and
participated and I have only read press
accounts but I'm told that maybe it
wasn't her best decision she was awful
she hated every second of it she
wouldn't laugh I got her to laugh one
time when I am one joke I think I said
you know Ann Coulter wants to help Trump
make America great again you can start
where by wearing a burka yeah and she
kind of smirked at that one what was the
roughest thing you said about her do you
remember oh I said how do I roast
somebody from Hell yeah I have to give
her credit she was out of her element
she agreed to come right and anybody
anytime somebody puts himself out there
I think that's a cool thing yeah do you
think she knew what she was in for for
there she had no idea at all right I
think she did but she's claiming she had
no idea I don't think she knew it would
be all basically when I heard she was
coming I stopped writing jokes about Rob
Lowe right started making Ann Coulter
joke I've told I'm told it's a great
roast cuz everybody really goes after
her and that the jokes are incredibly
intense and she could handle it you know
that she's the only woman ever to
sexually harass Roger Ailes nuts to do
it
you